hey what is up guys i'm kbhd here and
this is the oneplus x in my opinion the
best really cheap smartphone that you
can buy right now and even if you're not
gonna buy this phone it's still worth
knowing that a phone like this exists
this is oneplus super budget 250
smartphone where the whole point is to
give an impressive premium feel in the
hand at this low price and they do this
by using materials like metal and glass
all the way around which is awesome so
the flat edges have these ridged metal
rails all around the edges are all
chamfered and there's this 2.5 d sort of
curved glass on the front and the back
kind of like the iphone 4s or the nexus
4. so in the hand it feels really nice
it has some weight to it it doesn't bend
at all like some plastics would but
glass is definitely one of the
slipperiest materials possible so even
though it feels pretty premium naked
you'll probably want to at least slap a
skin on this guy so i'll drop a link to
one of those below that like button and
oneplus even includes this clear plastic
case with this phone so they kind of
already acknowledge this and of course
glass is also a fingerprint magnet in
this black color so there's also a white
version available that shows less
smudges but beyond materials this is a
classic oneplus piece of hardware so
power button and volume rocker on the
right hand side and the alert slider on
the left hand side really happy to see
that there and there's a decent speaker
on the bottom only the left grille is a
speaker and it gets kind of loud but it
definitely distorts at the highest
volumes now inside you have a similar
piece of hardware to i guess the oneplus
one so a snapdragon 801 adreno 330 three
gigabytes of ram which has been pretty
awesome for a budget phone and right up
front you have a five inch 1080p amoled
display and i gotta say
this is the best feature of the phone by
far i always love oled displays and this
one is no exception for me it's got inky
blacks and the super contrasty really
vivid saturated colors we love and this
one's actually pretty bright too so
that's nice usually you see a big drop
off in the display quality of budget
smartphones but this display despite it
being you know a little cooler color
temperature and a little bit smaller
than most is legitimately quite nice and
then to capitalize on this oled display
oneplus has some tweaks in oxygen os
just for this phone to use black more
often which you might know saves battery
in an oled so there's a dark mode going
on throughout the os dark background in
the app drawer dark background in the
settings app a darkened panel behind
your quick settings and even includes a
bunch of new wallpapers featuring pitch
black although the one i'm using now is
not one of the included ones so i'll
include that below in case you want to
rock it on one of your oled phones and
yeah performance throughout the os is
pretty nice pretty clean and smooth
again top-notch for a true budget phone
this is still technically on top of
android 5.1 so you'll note that i'm
hoping it'll get a marshmallow update
soon enough which will make it an even
sweeter deal and oneplus is pretty good
about software updates so even before
you get marshmallow you get features
like control over the app permissions
which is built into oxygen os and
customization features are everywhere
you can change the accent color of the
whole os in this dark mode so it's cyan
by default but there's a whole bunch of
contrasty bright presets and you can
choose between on-screen or off-screen
buttons also as you're accustomed to in
other oneplus phones you can use custom
icon packs and you can go through and
change all kinds of stuff like the order
of the quick settings toggles and all
the stuff in the shelf panel to the left
of your home screens etc all this stuff
is familiar from more expensive phones
like the oneplus 2 and you might not
realize it at first but it's kind of
nice to have these usability features
and nice to have stuff usually it's
stripped down from lower end phones just
to sort of make sure there's a clear
distinction but not so here this is a
very complete software experience really
all the same stuff that we love about
the oneplus 2 and also battery life
battery life was good for me uh it's a
roughly 2500 milliamp hour battery and i
was getting around three and a half
hours of screen on time so ending the
day with a bit of battery to spare
mostly with brightness in your max and
the usual you know social stuff watching
videos it handled occasional web
browsing all that stuff fine i think we
can thank the oled display for a lot of
those battery savings and you can't
forget to mention the expandable storage
this phone can hold either two sim cards
or one sim card and one micro sd card
and lastly the camera another area where
budget smartphones usually fall off
pretty hard the oneplus x is rocking a
13 megapixel camera with an f 2.2
aperture
and it's actually all right it relies
pretty hard on image processing since
there's no hardware stabilization but
photos in normal light look nice and
pretty much what you would expect from
any smartphone decent sharpness pretty
tame colors though a kind of a weak
dynamic range without hdr and then
getting into low light it doesn't
completely break down like some other
budget smartphones but it kind of hangs
around which is nice to see and really a
lot of the photo taking experience is
helped by the fact that the camera app
in oxygen os is so quick and simple so
there's like almost no shutter lag i
really missed a shot with it plenty of
smartphones in all kinds of budgets
really struggle with the camera being
slower but this is definitely not one of
them so at the end of the day this is
definitely my favorite super inexpensive
smartphone coming in at that 250 bucks
but
don't get fooled into thinking that this
is the complete package you definitely
get what you pay for and to get a
smartphone down to a low price like this
as we know with oneplus you do have to
take quite a few shortcuts and cost
cutting is real so no nfc in this phone
no 802.11 ac wi-fi no 5 gigahertz wi-fi
no usb type-c no rapid charging no
wireless charging no 4k video no ois
no raw photos and then one particularly
curious emission on the inside no bands
7 or 12 which will actually affect you a
little bit if you're a t-mobile or a t
customer i'm an att user and i'm pretty
much always on a t lte wherever i go on
this phone i spent some of my time on
lte but most of the time i was on 3g or
hspa plus because of the lack of those
bands and that might be a big deal if
you're someone who relies on a really
heavy data connection or you use that
all the time but if you don't then
that's less of a big deal to you so keep
that in mind there's plenty of corners
cut to make this work in a premium
feeling device for such a low price but
if you know what you're getting for the
money and you're okay with that then
this is definitely a great buy and i
would have any problem recommending it
so anyway that's been it that's oneplus
x now you know thanks for watching and
i'll talk to you guys in the next one
peace